"When I was four years old, as I well
remember, I was brought from Boston to
this my native town, through these very
woods and this field, to the pond. It is
one of the oldest scenes stamped on my
memory. And now tonight my flute has
awakened the echoes over that very water.
The pines still stand here older than I;
or, if some have fallen, I have cooked
my supper with their stumps, and a new
growth is rising all around." What we're
looking at on the upland side is the
site of Henry David Thoreau's cabin
where he lived for two years and two
months in the 1840s. It was a one-story, I think, 10-by-15 or
thereabouts structure with a window, a
fireplace, native wood; on the downhill
what we see is his viewscape, his view
of the pond towards what he sometimes
called "my cove" so he could muse when he
looked out over the pond and think that
he was seeing as far away as the Plains
of Tartary, as he called it. If there is
one bottom line, it would have to do with
the ability of not just Thoreau but any
person to kick start your own renewal, a
new beginning in life. At the very end he
kind of sums it up by saying, if you
advance resolutely in the direction of
your dreams, you will meet with a success
unanticipated in your common hours. Well, the more the
natural world, the other-than-human world
is under stress, under siege, threatened,
the more the eloquent testimony by the
self-appointed protectors, as Thoreau
often described him as being, the more
they become relevant and the more our
economy becomes interdependent and
people feel powerless, the more the
desire to break away.
That's another way of describing the
Thoreau bottom line in "Walden."
It's a breakaway book, a book about
breaking away from life as usual. "I went
to the woods because I wished to live
deliberately, to front only the essential
facts of life, and see if I could not
learn what it had to teach, and not, when
I came to die, to discover that I had not lived."